et can't confirm a Brad Pitt has finally  seen his son Maddox for the first time  since Angelina Jolie filed for divorce  this is also the first time since their  alleged incident aboard a private jet  last month the incident was reportedly  under investigation by the Los Angeles  Police Department and LA County  Department of Children and Family  Services Brad and Maddux's reunion took  place on Wednesday and a therapist was  present for it  this comes after Brad had a supervised  visit with his other children  earlier this month Brad and Angelina  currently have a temporary custody  agreement for their six kids we've  learned Angelina still wants her  children to have a brat in their lives  but she and Brad are not getting back  together the divorce is still hot